- So I, I heard,
is it true that you are super
passionate about learning
everything when you were
a kid about the Titanic?
'Cause I actually was obsessed
with the Titanic as well
when I was a kid.
I just found, I found it fascinating,
like something, it was just so gigantic,
like the whole thing
and like how it played out
and like even how like people were like,
how could you leave someone just drowning
when there was room in your boat?
Like, you know,
like all the whole thing emotionally
and just physically was so gigantic to me.
Is it true that you were just
obsessed when you were a kid?
- Yes, and this was pre movie.
There was a club at school
when I was in elementary school.
- Oh my God,
you were in a club!
- Called The Titanic Club
and we'd just to learn
things about the Titanic
and we'd all like build a little,
too bad. I don't have that.
That'd be such a great thing to have.
We'd like build little Titanics.
and I remember reading a book
that went like minute by
minute about what happened,
you know, during that night.
I mean, yeah,
I can't explain it, but yes.
- What is something you think that people,
I mean, even me, I
wasn't a part of a club,
so you might know more than me, but,
but what is something that you
don't think people may know
that is like random about the Titanic?
- Oh my God.
I'll be honest,
this was so long ago, like--
- You're like, you're like I don't know.
- The movie probably came
out when I was like 11 or 12
and this was pre that so.
- Yeah.
- Well my Titanic skills they're--
- They're a little rough.
They're not, they're not as sharpened.
Well the reason why I was too
is literally the Titanic
is what made me as a child
want to become a marine biologist,
'cause I thought it would just be so cool
to be in the ocean.
It got me into like the ocean,
all the, you know,
just all the stories that are told,
like even laying on
the bottom of the ocean
that you don't know.
I thought that was so interesting,
but I just thought it was
a random fact about you too
and I love that you were in a club.
(laughing)
- I was very cool.
Like when I think people,
when I tell people that
they're just like, excuse me.
(laughing)
- They're like,
maybe don't tell people that.
(laughing)